okay good afternoon everyone we're going
to start with the afternoon session
so it's my pleasure to introduce costas
duskalakis who's a professor at mit in
the east department
and he's also an investigator in the
foundations of data science institute
he works on the theory of computation
its interface with game theory economics
probability
theory machine learning and statistics
he studied equilibrium mechanism design
and the interface of property testing
and high dimensional statistics
he's won a large number of awards
starting from the acm doctoral
dissertation award
for his phd thesis
um but recently also the simon's
investigator award the nevin lina prize
which has been renamed the abacus medal
um and many many other awards and i
guess without further ado i'll pass it
on to costas thank you
all right hi everybody
uh thank you very much for the great
honor to speak at the 10th anniversary
of
[Music]
the simons institute it's uh
no better place to celebrate uh
achievements of theoretical computer
science over the past uh 10 years but
also
uh you know also the foundations that
relate before those 10 years for these
developments to
take place
this talk is about some interesting
points of contact between
theory of computation optimization
machine learning and game theory
and it's about multi-agent learning
so as you you know all know
machine learning over the past 10 years
have made important uh breakthroughs
and
um these breakthroughs are already uh
uh you know been used in real life so
from image and
speech recognition to translation
these are definitely in the real world
and you know a lot of recent
developments in text generation and
protein folding are
bound to have a lot of impact in our in
our world
uh so from a
optimization standpoint
the
for for for the most part
um a lot of how these breakthroughs are
attained
is to write a learning problem as an
optimization problem
that typically involves a high
dimensional very high dimensional
variable
a loss function that is typically
non-convex
but uh which at least is lipsets and
smooth
at least almost everywhere
and to uh try to solve this problem
which is
very hard because this the function is
non-convex with a very simple method
namely gradient descent or some variant
of gradient descent
now
because the function is not convex
there's no guarantee grading this end is
going to get to global optimum
which is sort of like the fixation of
you know
for for a large part of theory of
computation but
uh nevertheless we have a guarantee that
uh
gradient descent will get to a local
optimum
and uh the empirical finding is that
this local optima are pretty good in
many
applications
so now
this empirical funding is so
uh common that uh this has led to
a very common paradigm in in this space
which is uh
for a learning application that you're
interested in
write a very complex model
like a large neural network of some
architecture
collect a lot of training data
write down a loss function that
expresses how well your model does
on the training data
and get access to supercomputer and try
to minimize your loss function
using uh the simple procedure i was
talking about before
and
this is a framework okay so again we
have we have no guarantee that we're
going to get global optima but
at least we know we're going to get to
local optima and
there's a there's an optimization
framework that allows us to you know
write models and train them using
gradient descent
uh the success is so hard that uh you
know there's a you know
a debate going on right so a lot of
people are
very gung-ho about this paradigm
actually
uh working modulo the size of the models
that you can write and train
again this debate of scale is all you
need is
a recurrent debate a recurrent opinion
uh in in in in this field
which of course uh has a lot of people
agreeing and a lot of people disagreeing
with it
uh now that that's not uh single agent
learning is not the topic of this talk
i want to talk about
a type of learning where this scale is
all you need
is not an opinion that is
supported a lot because
it's pretty clear that scale is not all
you need definitely is not all you need
and this is the
context of multi-agent learning
so a lot of emerging applications
a lot of emerging applications in
machine learning is involve
settings that are either
explicitly
multi-agent
like playing complex games
and multi-robot interactions or
you know self-driving cars interacting
with us other sales driving cars on the
road or with humans on the roads
or which are implicitly multi-agent
these are like uh deep generative models
and uh training
classifiers that are robust against
their serial attacks
these are applications that
are not born
as multi-agent learning problems but
they're a multi-agent learning
formulation uh helps you obtain
a learning goal that is uh
um
you know otherwise a single agent
learning goal so
uh just you know just to put a
context around
uh
sort of like
the challenges that arise in this kind
of settings let me talk about one of
those applications that are implicitly
multi-agent
and in particular talk about generative
other deep generative models
which are
[Music]
whose goal is the following
their goal is to come up with a neural
network
with our well-tuned parameters x
such that um
when you plug into this neural network a
boring sample
so a sample from say a high dimensional
gaussian
what you see in the output is an
interesting sample
in this case
a sample from uh
the distribution of celebrities okay so
what you're thinking is that there is a
distribution over faces
that could be uh celebrities sitting in
platonic space
and what you see in the real world is
samples from that platonic distribution
what you want to do is you want to train
a neural network that
generates samples
of faces that could be
celebrities such as the faces that you
see here which are not real people but
which are hallucinated by some neural
network
that's the goal of tip generative models
and
again so the this is the goal in deep
territory moles and
uh here's how a game theoretic
formulation helps you attain this
learning goal
[Music]
in what are called uh generative
adversarial networks
first proposed by goodfellow
uh the way you get your hands at the
neural network that does you know
this job that i described
is you create you set up a two player
zero sum game
between a player controlling the
parameters of this generator network
that you want to arrive at
and then another player who's
controlling parameters of a different uh
neural network called the discriminator
network
and
you
re you know you set up the payoff
functions of these two agents in this
game so that
at equilibrium of this game
the generator is generating good images
so
so the generator's goal is to take
boring samples and create
interesting samples
the discriminator's goal is to
take samples that are either fake
or real from the real celebrity
distribution and distinguish which are
which are
fake and which are real okay
so you set up this game and you
train these two agents to equilibrium
at the hopes that in the equilibrium the
generator is fully the discriminator and
also
generating good images
there are many proposals for how to set
up loss functions for these two agents
in this game
so here's one proposal
which leads to what are called vassar
steam guns proposed by archowski ital
so
in vassar stingans you
reward the discriminator to output high
numbers for
real images and low numbers for fake
images and give the opposite loss to the
the opposite uh yeah so like around in
terms of losses you can write in terms
of utilities
but uh
uh basically here
the loss of the generator is the
difference between
the expected output of the discriminator
on a real input
versus the expected payout the expected
output of the discriminator on an input
gen on an output generated by the
generator
uh and and you know the minus of that is
the loss for the discriminator now
um what you hope is that at the
equilibrium of this game
the generator is
completely fooling the discriminator and
this difference is zero
i mean this game trivially has uh
because you know the discriminator can
always take a minus sign
uh you know
trivially the discriminator is in better
place
and what you hope is that the generator
can can get the loss down to zero
uh now okay so this is all just
background so the starting point though
for this talk is that you know as you
can see uh
the loss functions involved in this
game are non-convex because they involve
neural networks that are composed of
each other and so forth
and they're also high dimensional
because these neural networks have
millions or billions of parameters
and these gains have no equilibria
okay so for
a game to have equilibria you need that
the loss function
is convex in a player's own actions
and here you have a game where this is
not the case
and without equilibrium what is even the
optimization target in this case
so this is the
this is the
motivating question for this talk
so without much clarity about this
in practice people still trying to train
gans
and the way they do it is with a method
that they know how to
run i mean the method that works in
single agent
which is great in descent so they have
both the agents
around grading descent
with respect to their own variables on
their own loss function
so you have the
generator run great and descend on his
loss function you have the
the discriminator around granite center
on her loss function
at the same time
and you hope that something good is
going to come out of this process
now the empirical finding is that this
doesn't
work
at least definitely does not work out of
the box
in the same way that gradient descent
works out of the box
in single agent learning so in
multi-agent learning the picture is very
complex so
creating descent against creating
descent is
unstable
and it requires a lot a lot of effort to
you know make it go somewhere reasonable
let me show you two common failure modes
for gradient descent against gradient
descent in this setting
in the first example the target
distribution i don't know if you can
read to see this but the target
distribution is handwritten digits
and
what what you see here is what happens
if i run gradient descent against
gradient descent and stop the training
at some number of steps
and and look at what the generator is
outputting uh if i stop the training at
that step
so as you can see like so the generator
uh you know if i stop it after 10k steps
you know
collapses to a single mode that is
generating a like a weird symbol
then after a while you know goes to a
different symbol and then eventually
settles to a single mode on a
yet another garbed symbol okay so
you have mod collapse and you collapse
to mode that is not even in the support
of your distribution
in the other example which is where the
target distribution is a mixture of
gaussians you see another common pattern
which is that uh the recycling
so here the if you stop the training at
different steps
the generator is picking different modes
of this underlying
mixture distribution and generating on
that mode until the discriminator
catches up with them
and so on so forth so they're chasing
each other
so and that's very common okay so like i
you know predicts i mean it's
clear from these emerging applications
that
we are going towards a world where
there's going to be multiple agents
all endowed with complex
models involving neural networks that
are going to interact with the world
collecting samples making decisions and
changing the state of the world
and in that future
or present
you know we know that grading descent
against creating descent is not the
algorithm that is going to
lead to good models because it has these
issues that i was talking about before
it is unstable
uh so
you know so so this raises the question
okay so like
how should we extend this paradigm that
worked well for us in the single agent
setting to the multi-agent world
or more concretely
is are there meaningful optimization
targets
in this setting
and are they practically attainable
via some
nice method like creating descent
so these are the two the the questions
that i want to ask
um okay so let let's put some mathem
like some notation around the question
so
the types of applications that i'm
thinking about are those involving
a bunch of agents
every agent is making a high dimensional
decision
and every agent is interested in a loss
function that depends on their own
decision
and the decisions made by the other
people
and
you know so what makes it a non-standard
game is that these loss functions that
each of them wants to minimize are not
convex in their own choices
okay and you know more more specifically
the types of sets i'm interested in
are those where again that make each of
them makes a high dimensional decision
maybe the actions the strategies are a
couple like they must satisfy some
couple constraints maybe like one agent
is imposing constraints on the other
agent like
if somebody produces you know
10 kilos of you know bananas
the other person can buy at most 10
kilos of bananas so there are some
constraints s
on the strategies
and again so what makes it a
uh sort of like a deep learning
setting is that these loss functions are
non-convex
agents have access to them through you
know cheap cheap access to them like
first order access so so zero order
access the first order access and higher
order access gets more expensive because
we're in high dimensional settings
but you know at least i want to assume
that you know
these functions are differentiable and
smooth at least almost everywhere
so these are the types of games that i
think
you know will comprise uh
you know that we will you know are
already of interest but we'll you know
become
even more in the future of interest
and i call those smooth non-convex games
okay
now the right term is smooth non-concave
games because
uh you know in in game theory
we're talking about utilities the
utilities should be concave and
in these settings utilities are
non-concave so the the right term for
game theories would be non-concave games
but
the right term for machine learners is
non-convex because we're talking about
losses
of course losses and utilities are
minuses of each other so
let's for us let's call them non-convex
games
and you know as i was saying earlier
don't convex games are bad because
they trivially do not have equilibria
here is a here's an example of a
zero-sum two-player game that has that
is non-convex and has no equilibria
you have two players each of them
chooses you know is supposed to choose a
scalar
now the loss of player one
is the different squared of these two
choices
the loss of the other players minus that
now this game obviously doesn't have
equilibrium because
you know if at the pair of points x1 is
not equal to x2 then x1 is going to go
and land on next two strat on player 2
strategy
but you know if x1 and x2 are equal
then x2 is going to get the hell out of
there okay so go as far as away as
possible
so this game has no nash equilibria
and because there has no nash equilibria
because this general class of games
i'm interested in has no national club
the question is what is the right
optimization target
if i were to extend you know deep
learning to this world
what should i um
what is the normative what is the
recommendation of
about what is a good
optimization target in this case
uh and is it attainable okay if
identified
all right so what is what what i mean by
meaningful here at the very least it has
to be universal it should always exist
if it's an optimization target
it should at least exist right
and it also should be verifiable with
information that players have
if the agents have only
you know first order access to their
utilities you know
being at
equilibrium should be verifiable with
that information that they have if they
have you know higher order information
maybe
it should be verifiable with the
information that they just have
practically attainable
it should be reachable through grading
descent or some similar lightweight
methods
right so that i can write my you know
tensorflow multi-agent tensorflow
package and you know
ask people to express their
problem in my package and you know
give them a bunch of
optimization methods to
you know optimize it
all right
so
all right so what is the what is the
reasonable optimization target well i
don't know
but
[Music]
here is a very weak optimization target
that you might be interested in
which is called local nash equilibrium
what is a local nash equilibrium where
it says that you know it's a point
you know it's a collection of strategies
satisfying the constraints such that
for every player i
xi star what they are playing
is at least a local minimum of their own
loss function
if you keep the other people's
strategies at you know the star values
and you were to allow this agent to
locally optimize his utility function
around x i star
it's a very really weak solution
consider that at the very minimum
you know like i mean if you're training
a bunch of robots doing things
there shouldn't be a robot that can
tweak their actions around what they're
currently doing to improve their loss
function
it's a very weak solution concept
it's not like
um
the you know the
necessarily you know like that strong
but you know at the very least you would
like to satisfy this
and and like the the weakest the variant
of that
is when this local min is a first order
local lead
so first order local nash is the point
where everybody plays a first order
best response
to their opponent's strategies
all right so
okay what does this mean mathematically
where
okay so x i star is the best response a
first order best response to
x minus i star means that it's the best
response as far as the first order
taylor expansion of their loss function
around the star is concerned
okay so what does that mean
if this blob are the constraints imposed
by the actions of the other players on
player i so this is this
blob player i must find himself in one
of these two possible states
either what they're playing now is on
the boundary of the constraint set
and if they were to do a gradient
descent step
that would take them outside of the
constraint set and if they were to
project back down into the constraints
they would land at the same point
this is like their you know they're
pushing against the boundary and
a first order step wouldn't you know
after they project back to the
constraints gets them back where they
are
these other the other possibilities that
they're playing inside the constraint
set but the gradient is zero so first
order steps don't go anywhere
or you know in math compactly this is
what it means right so it says
if i
were to take a gradient descent step on
their loss function with respect to
their own variables
fixing the other guys
and project back into the constraint set
they land back where they are currently
are so they're like okay
as far as my first taylor expansion of
my loss function is concerned
i can't do anything okay i'm kind of
pleased
so this is first order local match
right again it's a very weak solution
concept but at the bare minimum i
wouldn't
i wouldn't like to be a robot that has a
first order
improvement available right so like
it's a weak solution concept but it's a
you know at the very least i would like
to satisfy that other an optimization
target for multi-agent deep learning
now the good news is that
if the constraint set is convex and
compact
this thing is guaranteed to exist
um and i mean
all right i mean this is kind of like a
fixed point equation right i mean this
is no surprise
it really follows from brawler's fixed
point that this thing exists
so that's cool
that exists and it's also verifiable
with uh
first order information so agents don't
need uh you know
heisians et cetera to verify that they
are
at their first order local no if they
are at the first ever local nash
a little asterisk you might wanna
strengthen this definition and say okay
like how about second-order nas right i
mean not only do i wanna
[Music]
not have a gradient descent step but
also i want my hessian there to be
you know locally positive
sorry positive definite or something
you know you can extend this first order
local mass to a second order local nas
in this way
unfortunately you lose existence
so
you know you cannot
you know propose that as an optimization
target that always exists it may not
exist
actually uh so that you know so that's
the bad news but the good news is that
the first order one does exist okay
the question is uh is it practically
attainable okay so it does exist so
reasonable target does is it practically
attainable
well this picture suggests not right
because i mean
the fixed points of these dynamics that
practitioners are running in this kind
of settings
are exactly
this first order local now solution
right i mean
the fixed points of these iterations
are only going to settle at the fixed
point for the gradient descent map
which is exactly this first order local
nash equilibrium that i'm talking about
and um
in practice you know people have hard
time getting this to converge
uh is there some inherent reason
for for that this happens
so so you know you know one recent
result that we proved is that there is
indeed an inherent reason
and the claim is this that
even in uh
two-player zero-sum
non-convex games
any method that accesses losses
via first order
information
will have to make exponentially many
queries
in the dimension and
and or the approximation
that you're shooting for
to compute even an epsilon approximate
first order
local nash equilibrium namely
the point where this fixed point map
that i was talking about
you know
only makes an epsilon movement
but i mean if n equals one if you only
have a single agent this solution
concept is very tractable using gradient
descent
you can compute such things in poly one
over epsilon
uh time
and queries to the functions
so first order methods if n equals one
if you only have a single agent this is
computable
if you have two agents even if the
setting is zero sum
it's not computable
if it's a two player zero sum game with
convex functions it's also computable
because of von neumann's minimax theorem
and its connection to convex programming
all right but if you drop like if you
okay n equals one extractable
n equals to zero sum with convex
function extractable
but if you mix the two n equals two n
non-convex functions even if it's zero
sum
uh it's not tractable
in this sense that you need
exponentially many queries to get
an approximate approximate
first order local nash equilibrium
now okay maybe you have richer access to
the utilities maybe second order third
order whatever
that's not going to help you
so
a conditional result subject to the
complex theoretical assumption that
people is different than p
says that
any method will have to take super
polynomial time
in the dimension and or the
approximation
to compute a uh such a thing
again this is the previous one was just
a query complexity lower bound this one
is a conditional result subject to be
different than prepared
so you know in summary the results
you know as you hope hopefully this
audience know
paper is the class of problems that
contains p and is contained in np and
contains things like computing briar
fixed points and computing
nash equilibria in convex in normal form
games the standard game started
game theory
so what we show is that you know like
in the non-convex world even two player
zero sum games are intractable at least
as hard as any problem with prepared
an equivalent to these problems
but now i have two minutes
uh and uh i wanted to give an intuition
for the
proof
that's going to be a quick one
so why is it that uh
you know again a single agent non-convex
minimization is tractable
but the moment you introduce another
player in the picture it becomes
intractable why is that the case
well to see
some intuition about that
you know consider
uh you know objective improve objective
improvement steps in a single agent uh
minimization problem
uh so here i have an agent who's trying
to minimize an objective and controls
move in both the horizontal and the
vertical axis
and they're doing improvement steps of
the objective well at every improvement
step of the objective the objective has
to go down
which means that you know as you're
moving along a better response path
uh you make progress towards a local a
local minimum
and also
if your objective is bounded
from below
and if you're more greedy and you only
make epsilon improving steps
then you're chipping away
progress towards the
towards the local minimum
as you're making those steps and this is
why
gradient descent converges in poly one
over epsilon steps basically this is the
real reason this is the only reason
basically
um
in the two player zero sum case though
here's what may happen
um
so here i'm showing you uh better so uh
better response dynamics in a two-player
game where
one player is controlling moves along
the horizontal axis and one is
controlling muzzle on the vertical axis
and i'm showing you the objective value
of the horizontal player
well along horizontal moves the object
has to go down along vertical moves
the object has to go up because when the
vertical player moves they want to
maximize the function it's a zero-sum
game
now importantly though in uh two player
zero sum game
two complications arise so one is better
response things better response
dynamics might be cyclic
something that you cannot have in single
agent optimization right like when
singing legend optimization the
objective has to go down so you cannot
get cycles because
but here you can have cycles because you
can recycle three values and get cycles
so they're cyclic
and also
even if they're not if you if you query
some you know better response dynamic
that is non-cyclic that is a path
uh you get no information about how far
you are from the end of this path
because you're really recycling three
values
you get no information about where the
end of the path is even if it is uh
even if it is um a path let you know of
course if it's a
cycle you're not gonna you don't have an
end point
okay so to turn this into interactivity
proof
we would like to hide the long search
path that is you know
space filling and
you know where you query it everywhere
and you get no information about whether
where the local min maxes are
we were not able to do that unless i
mean what we did is you know to
implement that intuition we had to
first show the complexity result to show
that the problem is ppd complete and
exploit some structure of the proof
to turn some lower bounds for fixed
point problems to lower bounds for this
problem so we didn't know how to do it
directly
but we were able to do it as a corollary
of our complex theoretical assumption
and you know
the a big chunk of the issues were to
have a construction that gives rise to a
smooth function i mean like if you do
this construction this ppd completeness
proof you get discrete
objects
and uh to turn this discrete
discretely defined function on the grid
into a smooth function for the lower
bounds we're trying to prove
it wasn't that easy high dimension so we
had to do a lot of work there
long story short
[Music]
uh the philosophical core layer i want
to draw from this result is that uh
multi-agent deep learning cannot be
based on the same paradigm that
a single agent deep learning was based
on
and that we need to do a lot more work
um
interacting with uh
domain experts in the under in the
applications that we're interested in
to define the to model the setting
choose the learning the right learning
model and decide what are meaningful
solution concepts
and then also develop algorithms that
target them
which is really what took place in this
you know breakthroughs recent
breakthroughs in alphago and
poker these are not just deep learning
okay in fact poker has uses no deep
learning at all
all right so
this is my biased opinion of what are
opportunities
to pursue
i'm not going to get into those for the
interest of time there's a lot of
brewing work in this space
but the point is that we're working on
it
and topically there was just a
simon's program that was you know one of
them whose main motivation was
uh to pursue
problems of this interaction between
learning and games and you know
hopefully in the next 10 years we're
going to report on the progress so thank
you very much
[Applause]
hey thanks costas we're a little over
time so maybe we'll just take one or two
quick questions if there's anyone please
raise your hand
so
um
one possible intuition
while even in the benign things uh
like the two-player game could be very
very different than the the
the one player
is the following like intuitively if you
just have one player you could think
that every move improves your skill
level
but in two-players games it seems that
maybe once there is a gap in skill
there is no reason uh
for any further movement because the
weak player doesn't really have any move
to
they will always fail and then the
strong player doesn't have
uh any incentive to become better is
this something you see or is this
something you can formalize yeah so that
is the that is a one of the reasons like
in my slide about gans that's exactly
right like i mean this is one of the
reasons
that you see uh let's say the generating
player making no progress is because you
know like the discriminator is killing
the genera like it's
discriminatory so strong
that the generator has no local moves
available that could do anything
and there
it's important that the skill levels of
the two players their complexities grow
together you cannot have a
super powerful discriminator and a very
weak generator or the other way around
so there are some games of this form and
this is goes
into the bells and whistles that the
community has to add into the problem to
um you know get reasonably you know
reasonable practical results um
you know this you know like
joint
you know growing the complexities of the
two players so that's that's one
strategy
that they do in practice
i'm fascinated by the fact that uh
when you move away from one player
suddenly this zero sum
became
classically different but i'm also quite
fascinated by the fact that they still
stayed in the pid
somehow they didn't shoot our cpv right
what happened that to that direction
you mean why they stayed in speedpad
because it's a fixed point problem
ultimately what was there a follow-up
question so
yeah
yes the existence is because of that
like the moment you make the constraints
at non-compact then you lost existence
yeah a quadratic you cannot even with
compactness you cannot fix like a
quadratic even constraint equilibria
don't exist so that it's not an issue of
uh it's really an issue that uh it's a
non-convex game
but what i'm saying is the existence of
these solutions for story local nashes
it comes from
yeah the fact that it's a fixed point
problem ultimately yeah all right so
thanks again
you